I want to jump to the story from
Newsweek Donald Trump's properties will
likely be auctioned off attorney says so
where are we where are we currently
we're at the point where the former
president has been uh is facing 91 in
diamonds he's been charged he is facing
I guess the rest of his life in prison
his lawyers are facing several uh it
could be decades in prison
they're sanctioning other lawyers who
made arguments on his behalf they're
targeting Trump supporters as Maga
extremists the FBI is targeting Trump's
supporters if you're a trump voter or
Trump follower you're an extremist
according to the FBI it's this is this
is a leap from where we've seen it
before and now we're hearing that after
a judge summarily ruled that Donald
Trump must up dissolve the Trump
organization in several New York
companies a former Attorney at of New
York is saying that likely what they'll
do is they're going to liquidate and
auction off his properties Donald
Trump's properties will likely be
liquidated and sold off at auction after
a judge found he committed fraud New
York's former Assistant Attorney General
has said so it's not just some attorney
it's the former Assistant Attorney
General Tristan Snell was speaking after
a court found that former president the
former president had massively inflated
the value some of his properties and
ordered that some Trump companies
involved be stripped of their corporate
licenses quote
the worst outcome that could have come
from this case has already been handed
down and that is for the corporate
licenses to be canceled the properties
are likely going to be liquidated the
properties are probably going to be sold
at auction that's probably what is going
to happen we don't know that for sure
but that is probably where this is
headed so Trump is already really really
in trouble
did the courts prove that Donald Trump
commit fraud they didn't
the uh AG said here's our argument
Donald Trump's team said we have an
argument and the judge said I don't care
bang the gavel summary judgment you did
commit fraud because I said so that's it
Luke I'm with you uh make this man
speaker of the house now they now they
could effectively seize an auction off
his properties and just strip him of his
wealth you know when I I don't view
Donald Trump as doing all of this for
himself in terms of financial gain
I wonder if Donald Trump is doing this
for himself because he is filled with a
blind rage and wants revenge and I'll
take it yeah I mean look he knows that
these people have done basically
everything to try to screw him over and
screw the American people over and it's
very important for the powers that be
that you as an average person watching
what's happening in the media know that
this is what happens to people who stand
up to them this is what people uh who
are a thorn in the side of the
establishment are going to have to go to
in present day America it's a very sad
situation and we have to pray for him
he's really going through a lot and I
genuinely do believe that regardless of
whether I agree with him on everything
and there are certainly things I
disagree with him about that uh he's
doing a lot of this because he is angry
with the uh injustices that the American
people have faced at the hands of the
establishment over the past several
decades Kyle Surfer made a joke once
that um the there's so many stacking
human rights violations in this country
now that the country we used to live in
would uh would do a land invasion of the
current country currently live in no I
mean there's some truth in that and when
you look specifically at what's
happening to Donald Trump I think you
know part of me wonders if you you
mentioned earlier that the system is is
attacking him right now and he is the
lead candidate running for president
right now I think those two things while
certainly being correlated it's
difficult for me to suss out whether
that relationship uh is necessarily
causal and I don't know that you were
implying that it was but on some level
it seems to me important to them to go
after the front runner if the front
runner is challenging The Establishment
on the other hand I also wonder if even
if Trump was in last place they would
still be doing this because they have to
punish those who stand up to the regime
in many ways this is oh sorry no no no
no well let me just make one one point I
think you made a a very interesting kind
of observation because I do think if the
United States saw what was happening
inside of the United States they would
invade the United States in order to
restore democracy and rule of law so uh
it's it's a little bit ridiculous again
I've been a Critic of of Donald Trump
but this is clear political prosecution
this is clearly them doing everything in
their power to try to stop him and they
and the more that they do that the more
popular he becomes the more people
support him in the polls the more people
want him to become president of the
United States at what point do they
realize that that whoever they're trying
to stop they're also growing at the same
time well exactly and that goes hand in
hand with what I was saying earlier if
it was the other way around right and
the media was talking about how Trump uh
actually did nothing wrong and the
system was going after him for unjust
reasons then maybe the American people
wouldn't support him I think it's a
combination of factors people don't
trust the media anymore this goes uh
this goes hand in hand with what I was
saying earlier about the fact that when
their apparatus for propagandizing
people fails they have to use Force I
mean he is ahead in the polls all of the
the slander has not been effective at
reducing his popularity and so this is
what they need to do Mar-A-Lago is not
worth 20 million dollars that is an
absurdity on its face as a business
alone with no real estate assets it's
generating more than that per year the
real estate alone even if you want to
argue that it's got covenants or tenants
restricting its use in certain ways it
is still 17.5 Acres the judge is lying
these people are evil and they are
psychotic and what they are doing to
Trump to seize his his properties to
seize his money is communism 101. if if
this really comes down to it that they
cancel the license or Trump's companies
they lose on appeal and then they what
liquidate and auction them off at what
pennies on the dollar to strip Trump of
his net worth welcome to a whole new
ball game ladies and gentlemen there's
no way this judge is so stupid he
doesn't know that he's lying he's just
evil well and you know for your average
person looking at this again they see
Donald Trump an actual billionaire being
handled in this way by the system and I
think it could cause them to despair to
go well if he's not able to get through
this right if he's not able to leverage
the economic power that he has to escape
this kind of political prosecution what
hope is there for me yeah in many
respects what we're seeing is is
actually worse than an assassination
we've had assassinations in this country
where we've actually never had
presidents uh indicted like this and and
having their entire lives destroyed via
these liquidations and these
gang bang of lawsuits from every
direction but the fact is is
when JFK got assassinated or when Abe
Lincoln got assassinated
it was there was not an attempt to say
this is a legitimate course of action
there was not like you could say this is
a tragedy this is horrible but it's a
one-off thing that doesn't actually make
me entirely lose faith in the legitimacy
of the system because it wasn't system
approved what we're seeing now is
effectively an assassination and don't
kid yourself he's facing 750 years in
prison that's that's death that is a
that is capital punishment uh and I mean
that's
it's only 25 years for first degree
murder uh and and he's facing 750
without even on totally novel legal
theories so what they are doing to the
perceptions of legitimacy in in this
country by doing it this way is honestly
an order of magnitude more shocking I
wasn't alive for whatever was
experienced during JFK but I have to
imagine that
I mean how can anyone here forget this
for the rest of their lives and there's
always going to be a degree of cold
anger about what they've done to this
guy uh just for just for running for
office
well so here's the question for you guys
and maybe this is just a question of
whether you see the glass half full or
half empty whether you're an optimist or
pessimist but do you think that this is
going to terrify people and make them
feel afraid to do anything because Trump
can't escape these charges and they'll
feel like they can't or do you think
this is going to edify people this is
going to make them angrier with the
system I think you make them want to
stand up to the powers that be I I don't
think either I think regular people are
starting to get scared they don't want
to stand up to anybody they want to be
left alone when uh
you know I I'm hanging out with some
regular folks on the weekends just
apolitical nothing to do with this
playing at the uh the old poker tables
and uh some lib guy said I hate Donald
Trump but trying to get them off the bat
this is getting insane and I've heard
sentiment like this quite a bit from
regular people who are just like I don't
like Donald Trump I can't stand that guy
but man this is getting crazy and if you
if you if you look at that perspective
then go back to say 2020 or 2019. I
heard from a lot of people saying things
like I just wanted all to stop Donald
Trump won't shut his mouth he's so
annoying a lot of people felt that
everything happening in the culture war
and in politics was the fault of Donald
Trump yep and that if they just voted
for Biden it would all stop and it would
go back to us just plugging our ears and
watching sports and letting Obama blow
up kids and known as to pay attention
and then it got worse not only did it
get worse the economy got worse and now
they won't stop Trump isn't even
president anymore and they're trying to
put him in prison they're trying to
seize his properties and I think now
what you're starting to see from regular
people who thought voting for Biden
would get them out of this is these
people who got rid of trump they're
making it 10 times worse and now it's
getting very scary and I think a lot of
these people might actually end up
voting for Trump in fear thinking
we need someone to stop the extremism
and it's certainly we were wrong voting
for Joe Biden exacerbated the problem so
yeah well I'll let you guys respond
first before I interject with my point
do you think this is going to make
people more afraid do you think this is
going to edify them I I think looking at
the poll numbers I I think a lot a lot
of people are saying I'm just going to
support this guy I think we're also
reaching a situation where a lot of
people are um having their lives upended
under this economy I think inflation has
a big deal to
um to have this kind of sentiment of of
uh people being pissed off people saying
hey everything I had everything I I
wanted to achieve in this life is
becoming less and less achievable
groceries are becoming more and more
expensive under this Administration and
now they're doing a huge power grab
where they are trying to put their main
political opponent in jail this is a bad
sign for me this is a bad sign for my
country for my children and I think a
lot of them are concerned I think a lot
of them are also reaching a point where
they're uh encroaching such poverty that
they just don't give a damn they don't
care they're pissed off I think I think
a lot of these people probably won't
vote for Trump but they certainly won't
vote for Biden or whoever the Democrat
is because they're going to be thinking
in their mind I did this last time and
it got worse I'm just leave me alone
please I'm scared yeah I mean one thing
I would say to anyone who's afraid of
standing up to the system in any kind of
meaningful way because of what's
happening to Donald Trump is that when
you appease the left you show them that
the tactic that they're using works and
they double down they only get worse
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time